[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
pas possible ah oui bien ça va fort
ce que vous êtes dans la place
je t'ai dit ce slam à toutes les femmes
l'amour c'est comme une tartiflette
si tu as pas trop mal tu fais pas la
fête
[Applaudissements]
non je vais sortir vraiment la femme
donc les chéris alors qu'est-ce qu'on a
prévu envoyer envoyer on va chanter tous
ensemble c'est parti
que je fais lorsque je m'ennuie
j'adore
j'ai imaginé sans complexe
qu'un matin je changeais de sexe
que je vivais l'étrange drame de quoi
d'être une femme chez vous
n'ayant réussi la bagarre de l'autorité
du charme femme des années 80 moins
Colombine car le 15 ça champion des sur
la gamme qui va du grand sourire aux
larmes elle préfère
être un général infantile avant
conscience de jusqu'au fond des yeux
qu'on a envie d'appeler monsieur
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
je te le dis c'est bon
je t'expliquerai
la prochaine chanson non non c'est ce
bras là c'est comme la boule de riz
d'avoir passé les nuits blanches
ce que les cons ne fait
vous laissez imaginer
[Musique]
d'avoir perdu son enfance dans la rue
mais Naïm c'est pour toi des illusions
déçu
pas serrer la perçue
[Musique]
d'être tombé plus bas que la poussière
ça va toi là-haut et à la terre entière
c'est pour toutes les femmes qui nous
regardent
[Musique]
sans plus rien demander
qu'on vient de vous acheter
vous achetez
[Musique]
dans le regard vous
porte sur ses épaules
comme elles portent le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avant qu'on joue
avant qu'on joue la femme
[Applaudissements]
dernière chance
et après on fera aussi femme on est
obligé
mais compliqué mais
très fort
[Musique]
Martinez
ton corps bébé donne-moi ton bon vieux
fantôme
avec moi je veux
la
[Musique]
femme la queue yeah quand tu chantes
joues j'ai plus le moindre souci j'ai le
mal qui vit
ah alors dis-moi qu'est-ce qui se passe
un seul regard dans la face qui ne
ramène à la case départ là où je suis
parti
[Musique]
moindre souci j'ai le mal qui brille
dans la face qui me ramène à la case
départ là où je suis parti
merci c'est pour lui ça c'est pour toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal c'est pour toutes les
femmes
[Rires]
[Musique]
au début
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
des armes alors
il faut un perdant
et nous sommes nous les hommes pauvres
[Musique]
on se croit très fort en France vous
connaître
en vous dis sur vous répondez peut-être
[Applaudissements]
pardon on dit les vieux on a rien fait
plus beau
elle est très bonne mettons toujours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est bien on est bien là ah on est
bien
on est bien à toi mon grand chanter on
est bien là-bas si
yes
le premier pas qu'est-ce qu'elle est
belle celle-là
alors bon là mais pour toi là il connaît
rien
je suis pas chanteur
[Musique]
non il va repartir
à cause de toi
[Applaudissements]
insupportable tu vas voir comme ça va
partir
les gens qu'on demande là
c'est là que tu fais plaisir aux femmes
si tu rates le refrain en plus comme un
con ça va être maintenant ça va être
attention attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la chance de gagner souvent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
simplement je te le dis
que je t'aime
pourquoi je déconne le soleil vas-y
dans mes nuits
et je prends un silence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je te l'ai dit ces mots
[Applaudissements]
rien qu'à toi fais comme ça là
et il te diront
comment
du Léon ça fait quoi
tu as fait un homme de moi
silence on tourne
lumière caméra
jusqu'à que bon en douceur
je suis près de toi
moi aussi
on sera si beau
en couleur
[Musique]
salut allez-y simplement je le dis pas
que je t'aime
je t'aime
tu es le feu qui brûle
dans ton corps
pour me réchauffer en toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je crois sinon toi
[Musique]
tu sais que je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu as vu ce que tu m'as fait là oh
faut faire un
constats
[Rires]
est-ce que tu veux pas qu'on fasse
débarquez-moi c'est la préférée
[Musique]
c'est les années 80 les années 80 c'est
long on veut vous entendre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au secours
pour l'incant sur mes galères
petit à petit moussaille en papier
j'ai compris que mes rêves
d'enfants
un jour devienne grand attention
[Musique]
et je vous emmène au-delà de ce but
entre vous et moi
débarquez-moi
trésor et je vous emmène une fois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand tu passes un truc
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à toutes les femmes
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes la nature de demain
[Musique]
vive le soir et vive les gens comme
Cyril qui sont un peu les deux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je vous emmène au-delà de ce mur
entre vous et moi
débarquez moi
on va se toucher du doigt sans rythme
trésor et se sentir pour une fois
vraiment libre de faire le choix des
ine
[Musique]
ok
vous avez gagné on fait tout l'album il
y avait cette chanson c'est pas lui
alors c'est pas du tout ce que tu crois
de quelqu'un
[Rires]